we are the sum total of how we were
raised and the experiences we had we
when we were kids good or bad
and what i find remarkable when i've
done these and i've asked people tell me
a specific
early happy childhood memory and
sometimes
somebody will stare at me and very
uncomfortably say i did not have a happy
childhood
i don't have any happy memories um and
i'll say well tell me
a sad one then and i'll and so here
here's one of the actual things that
somebody told me
um they had a very a very abusive father
and one of the things they remember is
uh
her and her brother her baby brother
hiding from their father when he went on
a
on a rampage and she remembers holding
her brother and covering him up while
they hid in the closet and she tells
this
traumatic difficult sad story
and it occurred to me while i was
listening to the story i said
you told me about how you made specific
attempt to cover your brother to protect
your brother
that's positive in other words what
you'll find is even in difficulty
you will find these these these
strengths
that come out and that's who this person
was this person at her core
was a protector that she would stand in
the way of those
uh uh who who who might be harmed
in other words it was very very positive
i'm a great believer in the world of
balance
that um there's a cost for everything
that is good that happens to us
where everything we gain comes at a cost
but everything bad
um also offers some silver lining
there's always a positive in something
bad that happens as well
so the the one of the dirty secrets
about finding your why is you actually
don't have to have happy childhood
memories you just have to have childhood
memories
and there are still patterns in there
that reveal who you actually are
and so some of those coping mechanisms
though in their specific form
i would venture to say that there's
still some things that came out of that
that help
make you who you are that offer you
great value
[Music]